Professor Ben Polak: All
right, so last time we started
to study imperfect competition.
We looked at the Cournot model,
but the bigger theme is the
study of how firms compete
outside of the sort of easy
cases that you study in 115:
so outside of the example of
monopoly,
where there is only one firm
and so there's not much
competition;
and outside the case of perfect
competition where there are so
many firms, it's as if each firm
is a price taker.
We're going to continue with
that today, and in fact you're
going to continue with it on
into the homework.
So last time,
we looked at Cournot.
It was the model we started
with.
We looked at two firms
competing in quantities.
And just to review a little bit
what we did last time,
the kind of exercise there--so
I think,
is this right,
I think probably went a little
fast last time.
I was kicking myself afterwards.
People can nod or shake their
heads.
I think I went a bit fast,
so I'm sorry for that.
If there was a time to go too
fast it was probably last time,
because it turns out this is
something that's covered well in
the textbook,
so it's covered in chapter six
of the textbook.
But the kind of exercise we did
last time is a useful exercise
for those of you who are Econ
majors.
The way we solved that Cournot
model was we did three kinds of
things.
We did something very nerdy,
namely, we just played with
calculus and algebra.
That was sort of mathy.
We did something a little bit
less nerdy, that is,
we drew some pictures that
represented what we'd found.
And we did a third thing,
which we tried to match this up
to the economic intuition about
monopoly,
and perfect competition,
and demand curves,
and so on.
And this exercise of being able
to work in these three different
modes, economic intuition,
graphs, and kind of nerdy high
school math is a lot of what we
want to get you used to as
Economic Majors,
just to be able to translate
easily between those.
Again, I apologize for going
too fast but it's still a useful
exercise I think,
so have a look at it in the
book.
Now back to the lessons and
away from the nerdiness a
second, what did we learn?
Well at the end of the day we
learned that in the Cournot
Equilibrium, things were,
as we perhaps might have
anticipated--things sat
naturally between the extreme
cases.
So the amount of output
produced by the industry was
somewhere between the case that
would be under monopoly and
under perfect competition.
It was more than under
monopoly, less than perfect
competition.
Prices in the industry,
if we'd gone back and checked,
would sit between.
They would be lower than the
monopoly prices,
but higher than the perfect
competitive prices.
Industry profits would be in
between.
Industry profits would be less
than monopoly.
They must be less than
monopoly, since that's the
highest they could ever be.
And they're higher than perfect
competition, which of course,
has zero profits in this case.
Consumer surplus,
the benefits flowing to
consumers lie in between.
So in fact the model,
in addition to the sort of
nerdiness of the model,
it ended up with a result we
kind of believe in.
If you have imperfect
competition, it's somewhere
between perfect competition and
no competition.
But, what's the "but"?
The "but" is that there are
other ways we could model
imperfect competition,
and, as we're going to see
today, they yield different
answers.
So the first thing we're going
to do today is look at a
different form of competition
which is called Bertrand
competition.
The Cournot was competing in
quantities and Bertrand is
competing in prices.
Just a quick check and this is
not for the camera,
how many of you have seen
Bertrand competition before?
So, a good many of you.
So this is going to be review
still again, and for those of
you for whom it isn't review
don't worry.
We'll do this relatively
quickly but I hope I won't rush
it like I did last time.
If it's any consolation,
when I feel I've rushed a
lecture, I have a sleepless
night.
So if you had a sleepless night
because you're worried about it,
I'm having a sleepless night
too about that.
So there's two firms,
just as there was before,
and just as there was
before--so the players are those
two firms,
and just as there was last
time, they're producing an
identical product.
So the products we mentioned
last time were Coke and Pepsi,
but you could think of other
products that are pretty much
identical.
Just as last time,
we're going to assume that
costs are constant marginal
costs.
We'll assume that constant
marginal cost just as it was
last time is equal to C.
Just to remind those people who
are not Economics Majors what
that means, it means if I
produce 1 unit then it costs me
C to produce,
if I produce two units it costs
me 2C, 100 units a 100C and so
on.
Now what's different here from
last time?
I've already told you but I'll
repeat it.
This time, however,
instead of setting quantities,
instead of just deciding how
much Coke and Pepsi to produce
and spewing it out in the market
and letting prices take care of
themselves,
this time the firms are going
to set prices and let quantities
take care of themselves.
So the strategy sets this time
are prices.
Again, so as we don't get
confused, normally we use S for
strategy, but let's use P since
they're prices.
So they're going to P1,
will the price of Firm 1,
and P2 will be the price of
Firm 2.
This strategy set--formally,
let's just simplify it
here--let's assume that for each
Firm i they can set their price
anything bigger than 0 and
anything less than 1,
just to keep life simple.
So this is a little bit more
realistic perhaps.
Perhaps more realistic to think
of firms actually thinking about
what prices to set and then
adjusting the quantities they
actually ship based on demand.
Depends on--I don't want to be
too rigorous about that because
you could imagine the other way
around,
but if you talk to managers
this sounds more realistic,
at least for retail goods like
Coke and Pepsi.
So we know how prices are set,
they're set by the firms,
so the next question is where
do the quantities come from?
So how do--where do the
quantities from?
And they're going to come from
demand.
And let me use a big Q(P) to be
the total quantity
produced--sorry--the total
quantity demanded in the market.
So this will be total quantity
of goods produced by Firm 1 and
goods produced by Firm 2 that
are consumed.
So this is the total quantity
of Coke plus Pepsi.
Now we're going to--notice
there's no subscript on this P
and you'll see why in a second.
So we'll assume just to make
life simple, that the total
quantity produced is 1 –P.
And I'll say this and then
write it more carefully,
where P is the lower of the two
prices.
So total quantity demand is 1
-P where P is the lower of the
two prices.
Now to make that
lower-of-the-two-prices comment
a little bit more rigorous,
let's figure out what the
demand actually is for these
firms.
So what's going on here?
So let's look at the demand for
Firm 1, which is going to end up
being the quantity that they
sell.
So that's going to be Q1 and
what's that going to be?
Well it's going to 1 -P1 if
they're the low price firm.
So if P1 is less than P2--so if
they're the low price firm--if
Coke is the low price firm,
only Coke sells in the market.
There's no Pepsi in the market
and 1 -P1 quantity of Coke is
sold.
It's going to be 0 if P1 is
bigger than P2.
So if Pepsi is the low price
drink in the market then no Coke
is sold at all.
It's going to be (1 -P1)/2 in
the case where Coke and Pepsi
cost exactly the same.
These should really be--realize
that this is not exactly
realistic.
We're making a lot of very
strong assumptions here,
but nevertheless,
it's going to be instructive to
look at this model.
So we've got the firms,
they're the players,
I know what their strategies
are,
I know a little bit about the
structure of the market,
and I still need to tell you
what payoffs are.
And just as last time the firms
are going to try and maximize
profits.
So what's the profit for Firm 1
going to be?
I won't bother to write it
separately for Firm 2,
it's going to be the quantity
it sells times the price it gets
for that quantity,
minus that quantity it sells
times the cost it incurs in
producing that quantity.
So again, for Firm 1 it's the
quantity it sells times the
price, this is its revenue,
minus the quantity it sells
times C, the cost,
this is his cost.
I can rewrite that a little bit
more simply as Q1[P1 -C].
Where Q1, let's keep it in
square brackets,
this Q1 is this object here.
Does everyone understand what's
going on?
I mean the algebra doesn't
really help the intuition here.
The intuition is pretty
straightforward.
Coke and Pepsi are producing
this stuff.
They're setting prices.
If Pepsi is the low price then
Coke sells nothing.
If Coke is the low price it
sells this amount and its
profits are basically given by
this equation.
It's basically just revenues
minus costs.
So what we want to do is we
want to figure out what the Nash
Equilibrium looks like in this
market.
Just before we go any further,
notice that really this is the
same basic market we looked at
before.
Both times there's a demand
curve out there.
In one model we thought of the
firms setting quantities and the
market determining prices,
and here we have the firms
setting prices and the market
determining quantities,
but the basic underlying
economic structure of this is
very, very similar.
So to find the Nash Equilibrium
we're going to have to find best
responses.
So what we're going to do
together is to figure out what
these best responses look like
and let's try and do that.
So I want to figure out the
best response of Firm 1 as a
function of the price chosen by
Firm 2.
Best price for Firm 1 to choose
given that Firm 2 is choosing
P2.
I want to do this carefully and
slowly, and before I even start,
let me point out in passing
that calculus is not going to
help us here.
So for those of you who are
nerdy enough to understand the
next sentence let me just say
it.
This is a discontinuous payoff
function, so differentiating
isn't going to get you very far.
For people whom that didn't
mean anything,
it doesn't matter.
We're not going to calculus
today.
Okay, so there were different
cases to think about.
So one case to think about is
what if the other firm,
you're Coke,
what if Pepsi is pricing below
cost?
You're Coke,
what should you price as if
you're trying to maximize your
profits?
Somebody try and wave their
hands in the air if they know
the answer.
Pepsi's pricing below cost,
what's your best response?
The guy in there,
do you want to shout out?
Student: Just get out of
the market because it's not
worth it for you to sell
anything.
Professor Ben Polak:
Right, I've forgotten your name,
I should know it by now.
Your name is?
Student: Sudipta.
Professor Ben Polak:
Sudipta says get out of the
market.
If the other guy is pricing
below costs, you don't want to
sell anything,
that's the right intuition.
How in this game do I "get out
of the market?"
You're absolutely right,
I don't want to be involved in
this market if the other guy is
selling below cost.
How do I operationalize that in
this game?
How do I actually manage?
Ale is there somebody here,
just wait for the mike a second
and now shout it out.
Student: You could set
your price above his price and
then no one will buy.
Professor Ben Polak: The
answer was set your price above
his price.
So the other guy is pricing
below costs, the way which I
avoid making losses is to set my
price above his price.
Let's just make sure we
understand this,
if the other guy is selling
below cost, the only way I can
make any sales is to price below
his price.
I will then make sales but each
of those sales I'm making a loss
on.
I don't want to make losses,
so I just "get out of the
market," and the way I "get out
of the market," is by pricing
above the other guy.
Everyone understand that?
Okay, so now more
interestingly,
we leave a little gap here,
what if the other guy is
pricing above costs?
What do I want to do if the
other guy is pricing above
costs?
Can I get the guy with the
beard here, shout it out.
Student: You set price
below his but above or equal to
cost.
Professor Ben Polak: All
right, so if the other guy is
pricing above costs,
I want to set prices below his
so that I steal the whole of the
market and make profits on those
sales.
So where is--Suppose he's
pricing--We'll say the prices
are between 0 and 1,
suppose he's pricing at .8,
what would be a good price for
me to set?
Same guy, yeah.
Student: As small an
amount below his price as you
can do.
Professor Ben Polak: As
small an amount below his price
as I can.
So basically what I'm going to
do here is I'm going to set my
price to equal his price,
minus a little bit,
and I'll use the letter ε
to mean just a little bit.
I'll just undercut him a little
bit and by just undercutting him
a little bit,
I'm going to get the whole of
the market and I'll make as much
money as I can on those sales.
Now that's almost right.
That's kind of ninety percent
of right, but it's not quite
right.
I need to be a little bit
careful.
Now why do I need to be a
little bit careful?
This is almost right but it's
not quite right.
Yeah, same guy.
Student: You want it,
your price, to be at or above
cost.
Professor Ben Polak:
That's certainly true,
okay.
So that's true, fair enough.
So I want to make sure this
ε is not so big,
so as it pushes me below cost,
that's certainly true.
That's correct.
There's another little issue
here.
So here's the other issue,
there's a price in this market,
we might want to think of as
the kind of focal price as an
interesting price,
and that's the price at which,
the price I would choose were I
the monopolist.
Suppose the other guy didn't
exist, suppose Pepsi didn't
exist, so Coke has the whole
market, then we would solve out
this problem.
We would solve out what the
monopoly price is.
That's an exercise you did in
115.
And notice that if Pepsi has
priced above the monopoly price,
suppose Pepsi has priced this
good so high that it's above the
monopoly price,
then, as the gentleman said,
I can capture the whole market
by pricing just below Pepsi.
However, then I'll have the
whole market,
it's as if I'm a monopolist but
suddenly I'm pricing above the
monopoly price,
that can't be right.
I never want to price above the
monopoly price,
because I know the monopoly
price, when I'm the monopolist,
is the most profit I could ever
make.
Is that right?
So we need to be a little bit
careful.
This answer that says I just
undercut Pepsi,
that's true provided that Pepsi
hasn't gone above the monopoly
price.
If he's gone above the monopoly
price we need to be a little bit
more careful.
If P2 is actually above the
monopoly price,
then what's my best response in
that case?
What's my best response in that
case?
Yeah, can we get Katie who's in
green there, shout out.
Student: Pricing at the
monopoly price.
Professor Ben Polak:
Pricing at the monopoly price.
So if Pepsi is dumb enough to
price above monopoly,
sure I will undercut Pepsi but
I won't undercut Pepsi by a
penny,
I'll undercut Pepsi all the way
down to the monopoly price and
make monopoly profits.
I'll be very happy.
I'll be wondering what on earth
is Pepsi up to,
but that's fine.
So here my best response is to
price at the monopoly price.
There's one other possibility
here I've missed which is what
if Pepsi prices at marginal cost
itself?
That's the one missing case
here.
What if Pepsi prices at
marginal cost?
What's my best response in this
case?
Pepsi's pricing exactly at
marginal cost,
what's my best response?
Yeah, wait for the mike.
This is Henry I think,
shout out.
Student: To price at
marginal cost as well.
Professor Ben Polak: I
could price at marginal cost as
well.
How much profits will I make if
I price at marginal cost as
well?
Zero profits,
I'll make zero profits,
so that certainly is a best
response, pricing at marginal
cost as well.
What else would be a best
response?
That's correct,
but what else would be a best
response?
Price above that.
It doesn't really matter,
as long as I don't price below
it, I'm not going to make any
money anyway.
If I price below it I'm going
to lose money.
So this best response actually
is a pretty complicated object,
and we could,
if we're going to go like we
did last time,
we could take the time to draw
this thing,
but it's a bit of a mess so I
won't worry about doing that
right now.
So the best response is
actually pretty complicated.
Even though the best response
is pretty complicated--and by
the way, obviously the things
are symmetric for Player II.
Even though these best
responses are pretty complicated
it turns out that there's only
one Nash Equilibrium in this
game.
What's the Nash Equilibrium?
Somebody, what's the Nash
Equilibrium?
Raise your hands.
All you guys,
there's a huge number of hands
who said they had seen it
before.
Who saw this model before?
Fewer hands go up when they
know there's a question coming.
There's a different incentive.
Who remembers what the Nash
Equilibrium is?
Yeah, there's a guy,
Tae there's a guy right by you
there.
Student: At C.
Professor Ben Polak:
Shout out, even I can't hear
you.
Student: At C.
Professor Ben Polak: At
C okay, so the Nash Equilibrium
here, the Nash Equilibrium is
for both firms to set their
prices equal to marginal cost.
You can check that both firms
are then playing a best
response, so that's all right.
If Firm II is charging C,
then a best response for Firm 1
is to set price equal to
marginal costs,
and if Firm 1 is pricing at
marginal cost,
then conversely a best response
for Firm 2 is to price at
marginal cost.
Slightly harder exercise is to
check that nothing else is a
Nash Equilibrium.
Well let's think about that for
a second.
Suppose Firm 1 is pricing at
marginal cost and Firm 2 is
pricing at something higher,
at C + 3ε,
a little bit higher.
Suppose Firm 1 is pricing at
marginal cost and Firm 2 is
pricing at C + 3ε,
is this a Nash Equilibrium?
Let's think about Firm 2,
first of all,
is Firm 2 playing a best
response to Firm 1?
So I claim it is,
let's just check carefully.
Firm 1 is pricing at marginal
cost, the best response if the
other guy is pricing at marginal
cost is to price at marginal
cost or above.
Now this is marginal cost or
above so this is the best
response.
So if Firm 2 is playing a best
response, this is a best
response for Firm 2,
given that P1 is at C.
What's the problem here?
Nevertheless I claim this is
not a Nash Equilibrium.
Why is it not a Nash
Equilibrium?
Who has an incentive to deviate?
Can we get the guy way at the
back by the door.
Go ahead;
shout out.
Student: Firm 1's going
to want to produce at C +
2ε.
Professor Ben Polak:
Exactly, exactly.
This is not a best response.
The reason is that the best
response for Firm 1,
if Firm 2 is charging C +
3ε is to price at C +
2ε, thank you.
So it turns out it's pretty to
check that this is the only Nash
Equilibrium in the game.
Now what's the lesson we're
going to draw from this?
Well, as an exercise in Game
Theory, that really wasn't very
hard.
As an exercise in finding Nash
Equilibrium, by this stage in
the course most of you are
looking at that saying,
that wasn't hard.
So what's the point here?
The point is that in this game
in which firms competed in
prices, even though there were
only two firms in the market,
only one firm more than
monopoly, we get a dramatically
different result than we had
last time.
In particular,
we find that prices in the
market are equal to marginal
cost.
We find that profit in
equilibrium is equal to what?
Zero.
And we find there's lots of
consumer surplus because the
prices are really as low as they
ever could be.
In fact, the outcome here,
this equilibrium here is for
all intents and purposes,
the same equilibrium we would
have had had there been
thousands of firms in the market
and had this been a perfectly
competitive market.
So even though there's only two
firms here, with price
competition, identical products,
we end up with an outcome that
looks exactly like perfect
competition, except for the fact
there's only two firms.
The outcome is like perfect
competition even though there's
only two firms.
That's a pretty surprising
result.
It would suggest,
think of this as a policy
thing.
So if you believe this model,
if you think is really an
accurate model of society,
and you're a regulator working
in the Department of Justice,
or you're a judge trying to
judge some monopoly case,
or you're a commissioner on the
European Court or whatever
trying to judge some competition
case,
all you'd worry about is
getting one competitor in each
market, two firms in each market
and you'd be done.
You wouldn't worry about entry
beyond two.
Now my guess is we don't
believe that.
We'll come back to that in a
second, but let me make a
different remark before we get
there.
Is it me doing that.
Let me move this down.
Still doing it okay.
It's probably the wire.
Let me just remove it,
I'll shout.
Okay, I'm going to shout now,
can people still hear me?
Yep, okay thank you.
So we'll have to turn down the
other mike a bit.
So another thing to remark here
is, even though we looked at
essentially the same market as
we looked at last time,
and we didn't make any really
significant change--we just said
instead of thinking of them
pricing and setting quantities,
think of them setting prices
(happens to be just thought
experiments)--we ended up with a
radically different outcome.
So another lesson here is:
the same setting as last time,
as Cournot, but with a
different strategy set,
a different way of thinking
about what they're doing led to
a very different outcome.
That's worrying.
It's worrying because you can't
go away feeling comfortable
about this.
You can't think that it really
could make so much difference in
the real world how prices and
quantities,
and welfare,
and profit is going to work out
depending on some thought
experiment about how I think
about my strategy set.
So there's a little worry going
in about not just this example
but about the course,
about the whole theme of
learning Game Theory.
So what's going to save us here?
What's going to save us is if
we inject a little bit more
reality back in the model,
we're going to get back a more
sensible result.
So what we're going to do now
is we're going to relax some of
the assumptions of this Bertrand
model and it's going to do two
things for us.
First, it's going to give us an
outcome that we believe.
The outcome we believe I think,
is that imperfect competition
should look something between
monopoly and perfect
competition,
it shouldn't look like perfect
competition.
I think most of us don't
believe that two firms is enough
to make it a perfect
competition, that the regulator
shouldn't worry about the third
firm.
The second thing it's going to
do, from a more theoretical
point of view,
is it's going to suggest to us
that actually things aren't
quite as bad we thought.
In fact, if we model this more
carefully, we'll get roughly the
same prediction either way.
So what's the assumption we're
going to change?
Well before I say that,
I should say I'm not going to
change it, you are.
So rather than go through this
again a whole third time,
I've gone through it once in
quantities and once in prices,
I'm going to get you guys to do
it this time by having you do it
on a homework assignment.
Well why?
Partly because I think it's a
good exercise,
but also I don't want this
class to be a class where you
sit there,
with your cup of Willoughby's
coffee if needed to keep awake,
and you watch me solve models
because that's not how you
learn.
What I want this class to be is
a class where at least
sometimes, like on this homework
assignment,
I set up a model for you,
set up the story for you,
and then you have to actually
figure out how do I set this up
properly and how do I solve it
out?
Because at the end of the day,
if Game Theory is going to be
useful for you in your later
lives,
whether it's in dating or in
running a company or whatever it
happens to be,
you need to able to go from the
story to the model.
Having said that,
I'll tell you what the homework
assignment's going to be about.
The assumption we're going to
change is the idea that products
are identical.
So we're going to look at a
case, I'll use a new board,
where products are
differentiated.
I'm going to claim that
assuming that products are not
identical, is a pretty safe
assumption for most of the
world,
for most things that you're
going to see in the world.
So we're going to look at what
are called differentiated
products.
In particular,
we're going to look at a
particular version of this that
we're going to call the linear
city model.
So what do I mean by products
being differentiated?
So I started off with an
example that's pretty bad for
this story, namely,
Coke and Pepsi.
Now be honest,
how many of you in a blind
taste test can taste the
difference between ordinary Coke
and ordinary Pepsi?
Quite a few.
That's good for my case,
so a number of you think those
are different products.
So a number of you,
even if the price was just a
tiny bit different might have a
preference for one rather than
the other,
so without getting in trouble
by putting the camera on you,
how many of you would have a
preference,
if the prices were essentially
the same how many of you would
have a strict preference for
Pepsi?
How many would have a strict
preference for Coke?
preference for Diet Coke?
That's amazing,
that stuff's--oh never mind.
Okay but you're making my point.
The point I'm trying to make
is, products are not identical.
For the most part there's a
little bit of difference between
products and that's actually
going to--that is,
if we inject that little bit of
realism into the world--it's
actually going to help us.
So what we would like,
what would we like?
We would like a model in which
firms set prices because for the
most part we think firms do set
prices not quantities:
not always but for the most
part.
But we'd like a model that
yields an outcome that
looks--that when you only have
two firms looks somewhere
between monopoly and perfect
competition.
So we'd like an outcome that
looks a little bit like Cournot,
but we'd like the strategy set
to be prices,
and this is going to do the
trick.
This is going to turn out to do
the trick as you'll find out in
your homework assignment.
So how are we going to model
this on the homework?
The way we're going to model
differentiated products is to
imagine, just to take a simple
example,
imagine a city and this city
has one long straight road
through it.
So this city is not a city in
New England, it's a city in the
Midwest, where everything's flat
and the roads just go completely
straight.
You can think of this as being
a mile long.
It doesn't really matter,
let's just think of it as being
a mile long.
We're going to assume that
consumers are evenly spread
along this city.
So there's basically consumers
everywhere, they're evenly
distributed and we're going to
assume that one of these firms,
let's call it Firm 1 sits at
point 0 and the other firm,
Firm 2, sits at point 1.
Now, this is what you're going
to do in the homework
assignment, but I'm just going
to make the argument that you
could also imagine firms sitting
somewhere between 0 and 1.
We could do a more general job
if we wanted to,
but for now,
let's assume that one of these
firms has its shop at one end of
the town,
and the other one has its shop
at the other end of the town.
So let's think about a
particular consumer,
so suppose this consumer is
here, at point Y say.
So notice that this consumer is
a distance Y away from Firm 1.
So if she consumes from Firm 1
she has to walk a distance of Y.
She's a distance of 1 -Y from
Firm 2, is that right?
So if she consumes from Firm 2
she has to walk 1 -Y.
That's going to turn out to be
key in our model as we'll see in
a second.
So firms, as before,
are going to set prices.
I won't write everything down
because it's all written down on
the homework assignment which is
already on the web,
but in fact firms are going to
maximize profits,
aim to maximize profits,
firms are going to have
constant marginal costs.
We'll make one other assumption
to keep life simple.
We'll assume that each consumer
buys one and only one product.
Each consumer is going to buy
one product, either from Firm 1
or from Firm 2.
So the issue is going to be
which firm does each consumer go
and buy their product from.
Which firm does each consumer
choose?
We'll assume that each consumer
chooses the product whose,
and I'll be careful here,
whose total cost to her is
smaller.
What do we mean by total cost?
Well let's look at the consumer
at point Y.
For example,
for the consumer at point Y,
if they buy from Firm 1 then
they pay the price P1,
which is set by Firm 1,
but they also have to pay a
transport cost,
the cost to them of having to
walk all the way there and walk
all the way back.
We'll give a name to that
transport cost.
We'll say it's TY².
So Y is the distance they have
to travel and TY²
is their transport cost.
So this object here we could
think of as a transport cost.
If the same consumer buys from
Firm 2 she pays P2 + T times
again the distance squared,
so that's going to be (1
–Y)²
and once again this last term
is a transport cost.
Notice that these transport
costs go up in the distance you
have to travel and they go up
pretty fast.
They go up at rates squared.
So what you're going to do on
the homework assignment is solve
out this market.
You're going to assume that
firms set prices to maximize
profits.
You're going to know what
firm's costs are.
You're going to work out what
firm's demands are going to look
for each possible price they
could set.
And you're going to solve out
the whole Nash Equilibrium.
And then we're going to look at
that Nash Equilibrium and you're
going to think,
how does that compare to what I
saw in the Cournot case we
solved.
So that's on the homework
assignment.
But before I leave this,
let me just point out that this
is a little bit more general
than it might appear.
So here I've treated what makes
products different as being
where the shops are located.
So here I've interpreted these
terms here as transport costs,
and I've interpreted what makes
the products different is the
fact that one of them is selling
at one of the end of the town,
and the other one is selling at
the whitehead end of town.
But actually,
we could consider this model
more generally,
and let's just do so briefly
here.
So let me just redraw the town;
here's my town again.
I don't have to regard this
product, this line as being
distance along the high street
of the town.
It could be something else
about the product.
So, for example,
in whatever it is you guys
imagine makes Coke and Pepsi
different, it could be that
thing.
Don't quite know what that is,
but whatever that is.
Let me take an example that I
understand better than I
understand Coke and Pepsi.
So imagine we're talking about
beer, think about beer,
so this is the beer market.
This distance here could be
something like the alcohol
content or the flavor of the
beer.
You can imagine different
products therefore,
that are on the market,
positioning themselves,
or being positioned at
different points on the line.
So, for example,
up here if you want beer flavor
this might be Guinness,
which I can't even spell,
but you know what I mean.
If we think about the drinks
industry more generally here,
rather than just beer,
this would be Guinness,
this would be Poland Spring,
this is water and everything
else would be in between here.
So if we just go a tiny
distance in here,
this is Bud Light and so on.
You could put everything on
this line, I think there may be,
I'm not really allowed to do
this on this model,
the one thing I can't do is,
part of the truth is that Bud
Light might be down here
somewhere but I'm not allowed to
do that.
So leaving aside the specific
example of beer,
you think about some product
that has some dimension on which
it varies,
and we can use this model to
see how competition is going to
work in that market.
But now notice that this
transport cost is going to be a
different interpretation.
Now, instead of being the cost
of traveling that distance to go
and buy the product,
what's it going to be?
It's going to be that if my
preferred beer flavor is here
say, this is me,
my preferred beer flavor is
here,
then if I end up having to
consume Guinness,
I have to pay the price of
Guinness and I also incur some
costs because Guinness isn't the
perfect beer for me,
it's a little bit too strong.
If I consume Bud Light,
then I have to pay for the Bud
Light, I think it typically
costs less,
the price, the raw price is
less than Guinness but I also
pay an additional cost from the
fact that Bud Light,
when I drink it,
causes me "disutility":
we'll put it politely like
that.
So basically,
that transport cost is now the
lack of pleasure caused by
drinking a product that isn't
perfect for me.
Does everyone understand the
story here?
So you're going to figure out
what happens in this story very
generally, well not very
generally,
but in the particular case
actually on the homework
assignment, but I want you to
understand that there's this
much more general story
underlying this,
and this is a pretty good model
of a lot of markets.
It's the kind of model that
you'd see again if you went onto
graduate school.
Now I want to spend the rest of
today doing something quite
different.
But you'll see it isn't all
that different.
I'm going to go away from
studying imperfect competition
and go back and visit something
we studied almost the first day
or maybe the second day,
and that's elections.
I want to go back to elections
and why do I want to go back at
this point?
Well one reason I want to go
back is you'll notice I've been
putting up these lines on the
board and when we visited
elections on the second day,
we said that you could think of
that line on the board,
as being not just left wing,
right wing politics but also
some dimension of products.
So I want to go back again,
now we're considering the line
on the board as being flavor in
beer,
or location in a town,
and I want to go back to
politics now and go back to the
interpretation we started with,
so that left and right will end
up being left-wing politics
versus right-wing politics.
So I'm going to take the same
basic idea back to the politics
model.
We'll spend the rest of today
in politics.
So we're going to be doing
Political Science or Political
Science as it meets Game Theory
for the rest of the day.
We're going to study something
called The Candidate-Voter
Model.
This model is going to look a
lot like the models we looked at
already a few weeks ago.
In particular,
as advertised,
there will be a line and this
line will go from 0 to 1 and the
left hand side of this line will
represent the left wing and the
right hand side of the line will
represent the right wing,
so that's the same as before.
As before, as in the Downs or
Hoteling model,
we discussed already a few
weeks ago,
we're going to assume that
voters are evenly spread along
the line.
So we're going to assume even
distribution of voters on the
line.
We're also going to assume,
just as we did last time,
that voters are going to vote
for the closest candidate.
So all of these assumptions are
the same assumptions we studied
two weeks ago,
or two and a half weeks ago,
and which you actually studied
in your first homework
assignment.
Is that right?
But I want to go back there
because what I want to do now
is, I want to change some
critical assumptions of that
model and see that by making
those changes,
we're going to get some very
different outcomes.
So, in particular,
the new things here,
two things, one the number of
candidates is not fixed.
So the number of candidates in
this model is going to be
endogenous.
Previously, we looked at models
where there were two candidates
or on your homework assignment,
three candidates.
Now we're going to allow the
number of candidates to adjust
itself.
The second assumption we're
going to make which is new is
that we're going to assume that
candidates cannot choose their
position.
So the idea is,
any candidate who stands in
this election,
you know who that candidate is,
you know whether they're right
wing or left wing,
so they can't tell you they're
something else.
So candidates cannot choose
their position.
So this is a subtle thing
because you think about the
current election,
there's a debate about whether
Hilary Clinton,
for example,
can choose right now to be at
the center of the democratic
party given her past history of
votes,
for example, on the Iraq War.
Or on the other side,
there's a debate about whether
Mitt Romney can choose to be,
I guess he's trying to choose
himself to be on the right hand
wing of the republic party,
given he has a record of
governance, as being Governor of
Massachusetts when he provided
state healthcare for example.
So it's quite difficult in the
real world for candidates to
position themselves.
Voters tend to know that those
candidates have track records.
That's something we've
mentioned already three weeks
ago, two weeks ago,
we're going to take that fix
now,
we're going to assume you know
who these candidates are.
So what are we actually going
to assume?
We're going to assume that each
voter in the model is a
potential candidate.
So this is, I think,
a nice idealized version of
American politics.
Each of you,
who is above 18 and is an
American citizen,
and was born in America (maybe
you have to be more than above
18,
above whatever it is,
whatever the rule is,
whatever the Constitution
says),
each of you can potentially
stand up now and say you're
going to run for President.
I'm guessing all of you are
ruled out by age actually.
There's some rule in the
Constitution,
but never mind,
let's pretend that's not there.
So the idea of the model is
each voter is a potential
candidate.
That's a very appealing
assumption I think in a
democracy.
So what I want to do is,
I want to lay this out a little
bit more formally as a game,
and then, since we haven't done
anything like this for a week or
so, we're going to play the
game.
So you're about to play this
game, so pay attention please.
So who are the voters,
who are the players?
The players are the voters.
The voters, or candidates,
whatever you want to call them,
depending on where they stand,
in this game they're going to
be you.
The key strategy here,
essentially the strategy is
going to be very simple.
The strategy is:
do you run or not?
The reason that's going to be
the strategy is that voting's
not going to be difficult.
You're always going to end up
voting for the candidate who's
closest.
So the only really relevant
strategy is to run or not to
run, to stand or not to stand.
So just to make that clear,
voters vote for the closest
running candidate first.
And second, what did it mean to
win?
Well assume that we're in a
plurality election here,
so the winner is the person who
gets a plurality.
You win if you get the most
votes, in other words.
We'll assume that if there's a
tie that we flip a fair coin or
a Supreme Court judge,
whatever you want to take,
whichever.
Flip if tie.
The payoffs in this game are as
follows.
We'll assume that there's a
prize for winning.
So if you win the election you
get a prize equal to B.
We'll also assume that there's
a cost of running,
so if you enter this election,
win or not, you incur a cost of
C, and we'll assume that B is
greater than or equal to 2C,
and actually for today,
let's just keep things simple,
and assume it's actually equal
to 2C.
But that's not the only part of
the payoffs.
There's also a part of the
payoffs that's analogous to
forcing me to drink Bud Light or
forcing the Pepsi drinkers to
drink Coca-Cola.
What's that?
That's if, regardless of
whether I run or not,
if some other candidate is
elected other than me,
then they're not going to have
my ideal policies.
So it's going to cause me
unhappiness, it's going to cause
me disutility having a candidate
win, who's far away from me.
So there's going to be an extra
thing and, so if you're position
is X, if you are at X on that
line and the winner of the
election is at Y,
than you pay a cost of
–|X –Y|,
the absolute distance between
you and the winning candidate.
So again, if you're at X and
the winner is at Y,
it hurts you minus the distance
between X and Y,
in terms of your unhappiness,
about having a winner who's far
away from you,
winning.
So let's do an example,
just want to make sure we
understand the payoffs.
So Example 1,
if you're at X,
let's just call you Mr.
X, just to make it clear,
so Mr.
X is the person at position X.
If he enters the election and
he wins the election then his
payoff is B because he entered
-C,
--sorry B because he won,
-C because he had to pay his
election expense.
But the winning candidate is
him so he gets no disutility
from the winning candidate being
someone else.
Second possibility,
if Mr.
X enters but Mr.
Y wins, then X's payoff is
what?
He still incurred -C because he
ran and he also has a cost of
|X-Y| because he doesn't like
Mr.
Y winning.
Third, if Mr.
X stays out but Mr.
Y wins then Mr.
X's payoff, he doesn't win so
he doesn't get B,
he doesn't lose C because he
didn't run, but he still has
this disutility -|X –Y|
because he doesn't like Y
winning.
Does everyone understand this
game?
Everyone understand the game?
Anyone not understand the game
at this point?
In principle,
we could play this with the
whole class, but let's single
out a particular row of the
class so I'm going to come down
here and I guess eventually,
well I'll grab it in a minute.
So I'm going to use this row,
I think, everyone in this row
stand up a second,
and this row stand up,
this is the row of potential
voters.
They're the voters.
They're also the potential
candidates.
So we need to have a convention
here, whether we're viewing this
from the perspective of people
behind them or people in front
of them,
let's view it from the
perspective of the people in
front of them.
So I got an R,
I'll do it the other way
around.
People from behind that have
the perspective.
So this gentleman here who's
name is Andy.
So Andy is our crazy right-wing
guy and Sudipta is our crazy
left-wing guy,
everyone else is in between.
There's 1,2,
3,4, 5,6, 7,8,
9,10, 11,12,
13,14, 15,16 people here.
Let me add, let me make it 17
people so we have an odd number,
so go and sit in that row.
Okay, now we have 17 people
it's a bit easier.
Just want to avoid obvious ties.
So how is this going to work?
Everybody sit down again but
don't put your--keep your books
handy because this is going to
be pretty aerobic.
So these are the potential
voters and each of them is in
the position that Fred Thompson
was in,
two weeks ago in the Republican
Primary, when he's deciding
whether to run or not.
But in the real world that's a
sequential game,
people decide to run in some
order, we're going to assume
this is all simultaneous.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to hold essentially
this game.
We're going to ask everybody in
this row whether they want to
enter or not.
Let's make some real numbers.
Let's assume that B is equal to
$2, so the spoils of government
are $2 and entering costs you
$1, so C is $1.
And we'll assume that the
amount of disutility you get
from being far away from the
winner is 1/17th of the
distance,
each of these,
each place is worth 1/17th of a
$1.
Everyone understand?
So whatever 1/17th of a $1,
roughly $.05 for each position
away.
Everyone understand in this row
what we're doing?
I'm not getting any nods,
you guys over here you
understand what we're doing?
So on the count of three,
anybody who's entering this
election is going to stand up.
Ready?
One, two, okay what?
That's the opposite of what's
happening with the Florida
Primary.
Yeah question?
Student: I'm sorry,
who stands up on the count of
three?
Professor Ben Polak: You
guys have to decide whether you,
okay.
So if you're going to,
if you're running you stand up.
If you're standing you stand.
Let's try again one, two, three.
Stay standing and I'll come
around a second.
So here's our election,
and it's between a,
which way do I want to do it?
This is our left wing
candidate, this is our moderate
left wing candidate whose name
is?
Student: Alex.
Professor Ben Polak: Our
kind of centrist candidate,
maybe even this centrist
candidate who's name is?
Student: Beatrice.
Professor Ben Polak:
Beatrice.
So this is the election,
who's going to win this
election?
Beatrice is going to win this
election.
Let's just check that.
Beatrice is going to get all of
these right wing votes.
Beatrice is also going to get
one and a half of the votes in
the middle, so this vote and
half the Pierson guy's vote and,
I've forgotten your name
already, again?
Alex is going to get all the
left wing votes,
but there aren't enough left
wing votes here,
right?
So Beatrice is going to win.
So Beatrice won this election,
is this array a Nash
Equilibrium?
Is this an equilibrium?
How do we know it's not an
equilibrium?
Katie, how do we know this is
not an equilibrium?
Student: Because Alex's
best response to her running is
to not run.
Professor Ben Polak:
Absolutely.
So Alex here,
Alex ends up with a payoff of
what?
Alex ended up with a payoff of
-C, actually more than that,
-C minus the distance between
him and Beatrice,
so that's another $1,
$.05, $.10 or even $.20
whatever it is,
and he would have done better
to have not run.
If he hadn't run,
Beatrice would still have won,
but it would still have cost
him the $.20 of unhappiness at
Beatrice winning,
but at least he would have
saved himself the C of running.
Everyone see that?
Let's try it again.
Okay, same row,
but don't hesitate so much this
time.
Count of three,
you're just going to go or not.
Everybody in this row close
their eyes so you can't look
around you.
Close your eyes,
you can do all sorts of nasty
things, close your eyes.
Myrto you're still in this row
okay.
So one, two, three.
You can open your eyes again,
so now what happened,
we ended up with two centrist
candidates.
Let's see what happened,
so we have Beatrice and your
name is Claire Elise.
Student: Claire Elise.
Professor Ben Polak:
Claire Elise is going to get her
own vote plus 1,
2,3, 4,5, 6,7,
8,8 votes and Beatrice is
getting 1,2, 3,4,
5,6, 7, how did I end up with
eight,
I thought I had an odd number.
1,2, 3,4, 5,6,
7 there must have been an odd
number before.
So Claire Elise is going to win
this election because she got
one more vote.
Now here we ended up with two
centrist candidates,
which is a result pretty close
to what we saw in the Hoteling
model, is that right?
Is this an equilibrium?
So check that I counted right,
1,2, 3,4, 5,6,
7,8 and 1,2,
3,4, 5,6, 7.
I guess I did count right,
so Claire Elise turned out to
win this.
I counted that correctly.
There's another vote hidden
behind there,
I didn't see you.
Let's try again.
So 1,2, 3,4, 5,6, 7,8.
I apologize Beatrice won this
election, I apologize.
Beatrice won this election.
Is this an equilibrium?
How do we know this isn't an
equilibrium?
Because Claire Elise would
rather not have run,
is that right?
Let's try once more,
down again, close your eyes
again, just to keep life
interesting, let's switch to
this row.
Can we switch to this row okay?
So this is our row now,
everyone understand this.
Close your computer so you can
get up without destroying
thousands of dollars of
technology.
This is our row and at the
count of three we're going to
see who's going to run.
Everyone understand the game?
Close your eyes, 1,2,3.
It's obvious he's going to win
this election,
is that right?
Just to ask the question,
is this an equilibrium?
Let's count.
1,2, 3,4, 5,6,
7,8, 9 he's going to get 10
votes, including himself there
are 10 votes here.
I can't count correctly,
1,2, 3,4, 5,6,
is he actually the center guy
here?
I don't think he is the center
guy here.
So I claim, if I've counted
correctly, that this actually
isn't an equilibrium.
Who can deviate and do better
here?
This guy, stand up a second,
whose name is?
Student: John.
Professor Ben Polak:
Had John entered,
if I've counted correctly,
let's pretend I have,
John would actually have won
this election because John is
actually further to the center.
Okay, so let's,
thanks for a second guys,
I'll come back to this in a
second.
Let's try and figure out how to
analyze this game.
We've played it three times,
let's try and figure out what
the equilibria looked like in
this game.
This game that's going on more
or less right now in the
primaries, well I guess the
entry stage of it is gone now.
So first of all,
is there a Nash Equilibrium in
which no candidates stand?
Is there a Nash Equilibrium in
which nobody stands?
No.
How do we know that's not a
Nash Equilibrium?
Somebody?
Yeah, how do we know that's not
a Nash Equilibrium?
Shout it out.
Student: Because then
somebody's definitely better off
by standing up.
Professor Ben Polak:
Right, if nobody stands,
each and every possible
candidate would do better
individually,
so any particular voter would
do better standing.
They would win the election.
Is that right?
So clearly it's not an
equilibrium for nobody to stand.
That's good because we don't
see that very often.
Is there a Nash Equilibrium in
which one and only one candidate
stands?
Student: If they're
directly in the center.
Professor Ben Polak: All
right, so given that we chose an
odd number of people in the row,
if exactly one candidate stands
and that candidate is the center
candidate,
then that's an equilibrium.
How do we know that's an
equilibrium?
Somebody give me the argument
why that's an equilibrium?
It's a good,
in fact, it's a correct guess.
But how do we know that's an
equilibrium?
That's the guess part.
How do we check that's an
equilibrium?
Student: If anybody on
either side of them chose to
run, they would lose.
Professor Ben Polak:
They would lose,
exactly.
So if anybody on either side of
them runs, that person would
simply lose.
It wouldn't make any difference
to the outcome.
If a person on the right stood,
so let's just try it again.
So we figured out that,
Beatrice stand up a second.
So here's our potential
equilibrium with just Beatrice
standing, and if somebody to
the,
which way do we do it,
somebody to the right of
Beatrice was to stand,
so ma'am if you stand a second,
and your name is?
Student: Stacy.
Professor Ben Polak: So
if Stacy stands,
it doesn't make any difference
she just loses.
Beatrice wins anyway;
it just costs Beatrice some
money.
Conversely, if Beatrice doesn't
stand and the woman who's one in
from the side there,
sit down a second Stacy and if
this person stands,
and your name is?
If Sarah stands,
it doesn't help Sarah at all,
she just loses.
Is that right?
So there is an equilibrium with
exactly one candidate,
the center candidate.
Now that's looking a little bit
like the median voter model.
It says there is an equilibrium
with only one candidate standing
and that candidate would be the
median candidate,
just like it was in the model
we saw on your homework
assignment and also in class.
However, we're not done yet,
there could be other
equilibria.
So let's just try and think
about whether there are other
equilibria.
So, for example suppose now,
just to make life a little bit
more interesting,
suppose that the voters were
actually two rows and just allow
me the suspension of disbelief
that these rows have the same
number of people in them,
I know they don't really.
So now what I want you to think
of is that at every political
position there are two voters,
and hence two possible
candidates.
There's two people at every
position, these two people at
this position,
these two people at this
position.
Everyone understand that?
Let's just assume that the rows
are the same even though they're
not and let's examine the
following thing.
Suppose Beatrice stands again,
sorry Beatrice,
and the gentleman in front of
her whose name is?
Robert stands as well,
so stand a second.
So now we have two candidates
standing who are identical,
politically,
they're identical.
They're right on top of each
other.
Now is that an equilibrium?
After all that looks a lot like
the Downs-Hoteling model,
we've got two candidates
exactly at the middle,
is that an equilibrium?
Let me try the guy up here?
Student: No,
because if someone on either
side of them were to stand up
that person on the side would
win.
Professor Ben Polak:
Good, this can't be an
equilibrium because look what
happens if Claire Elise stands a
second.
Claire Elise is going to win
all of the right wing votes,
ranging from crazy to moderate,
and these guys are going to
split the left wing votes.
So the total sum of right wing
votes is going to beat out half
of the left wing votes.
So it can't be an equilibrium,
the exact prediction of the
Downs model, two guys right on
top of each other is not an
equilibrium.
Sit down again guys.
Let's go back to one row again
because it's easy to work with.
Let's try a slightly different
pattern.
So suppose, assuming I counted
right, suppose that the
following candidates enter.
So Claire Elise enters and I'm
sorry I don't know your name,
Jean enters so let's have a
look at this array.
Assume I got it right and
Beatrice is actually the center.
Now is that an equilibrium?
Who thinks that is an
equilibrium?
Who thinks it's not an
Who's waiting to see how other
people vote?
Well let's check.
So there's three possible types
of deviation here that we need
to check.
We need to check another
entrant from the outside,
left wing or right wing,
we need to check another
entrant in the middle,
there is only one possible one
there, and there's a third kind
of deviation we should check,
what's the third type of
deviation?
One of these might choose not
to run, one of you might choose
not to run.
Let's do them in turn.
So suppose that we consider a
deviation in which,
and again I've forgotten your
name in which Stacy stands as
well.
Stacy, just stand a second.
So is this a profitable
deviation for Stacy?
No it's not.
Why isn't it a profitable
deviation for Stacy?
So two reasons:
one is that she loses,
she's not going to win this
election by standing.
But there's a second reason why
this is a really bad deviation.
Why is it, what's the second
reason?
Yes sir.
Student: The winner is
going to be farther away from
her.
Professor Ben Polak:
Good, so by standing not only
does she not win the election,
but she actually causes the
election to be won for sure by
Jean who's further away from
her.
So Stacy's going to pick up the
right wing votes,
she's going to split.
The crazy right wing votes
she's going to pick up.
The moderate right wing votes
she's going to split with Claire
Elise, and Jean's going to have
all the left wing votes,
extreme and moderate,
and so from Stacy's point of
view this is a double bad.
She doesn't get to be
President, sorry and you end up
with a left wing President,
which you didn't like.
Everyone see that?
So clearly, that's not,
thank you, that's not a
profitable deviation and it's
also not a profitable deviation
for people on the left.
Hang on a second.
So I think it's probably
obvious why it's not a good
strategy for Beatrice to enter
here.
If Beatrice enters she loses.
Everyone can see that?
The person in the middle if
they enter here loses,
so they're not going to want to
enter.
So the other possible deviation
we have to consider,
is a deviation of the form of
one of these guys dropping out.
So let's consider it,
so come back to Claire Elise.
Is Claire Elise doing better in
or out?
this election or out?
Let's think it through a
second, if she stays in what's
her payoff?
She wins B with probability a
half.
She costs C for sure,
that's a wash because B,
the way we've worked things
out, B was $2,
C was $1, so B/2-C is a wash.
In terms of the benefits
of--the spoils of government
versus the cost of running,
it's a wash for Claire Elise,
whether she enters or not.
But by entering she has a half
chance of winning the election.
So one way to think about it
is, is the expected distance
from her of the winning
candidates,
is: with probability of a half
it's herself so that's nothing,
no distance,
and with probability of a half
it's two places away.
So in expectation it's one
place away.
If she drops out,
Jean wins for sure,
so the expected distance away
from her of the winning
candidate is two away.
Just to say it again,
so the cost and direct benefits
of government are a wash for
her.
But by dropping out she insures
that somebody further away from
her wins for sure.
That's bad so she's going to
stay in.
The same argument goes the
other way, so this is an
equilibrium.
Now we're not done and of
course we're out of time,
so what are we going to do when
we come back next week?
Don't pack up yet,
what are we going to do?
We're going to come back to
this row and we're going to
figure out not just this
equilibrium, but all equilibria.
Before you go though,
let's just think about it a
second, so you can think about
it and talk about it at home,
so what we just saw was an
election in which we saw two
candidates, Jean and Claire
Elise,
who both stood very close to
each other.
But a different question
is--before you go:
stand up my very left-wing guy,
Sudipta, way at the end,
and stand up my very right-wing
guy.
Here's a candidate--here's an
outcome with two entrants in it,
an extreme right-wing guy and
an extreme left-wing guy.
Is that an equilibrium?
Think about it until we come
back on Monday.